[Musique]
2 il
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui je
reçois elisa benizio elle est comédienne
elle appartient à la compagnie des
mauvais élèves on les connaît on les a
déjà reçu c'est notre rendez vous du
mois de juin car dans le cadre du mois
molière ils vont donner un spectacle
les 29 et 30 juin on en parle et les à
benicio bonjour bonjour quand ça va mal
ça va super en plein travail rêverie et
là on bosse bon alors nous c'était donc
comme j'aime le dire déjà vu puisque
c'est vous êtes en résidence à
versailles en fait une compagnie en
résidence les mauvais élèves alors vous
êtes vous puis il ya les autres y est
vous êtes 4 total on va les sites et
donc bérénice coup dit valentin valérian
b argonnaise
valérien verts venaient entre mme
richard voilà tous les quatre vous
existez de python l'accompagnant l'a
créé en 2013 d'accord et donc ça fait
neuf ans qu'on devant ouais quand qu'on
est ensemble et on a là on est en train
donc les amoureux de molière c'est notre
cinquième spectacle un spectacle voilà
il s'intitule les amoureux de molière
faut quand même savoir que c'est le 400e
anniversaire de molière dont qui se fête
dignement
c'est la 26e édition
voilà vous jouez comme d'habitude j'ai
envie de dire dans les grandes écuries à
versailles vous réservez vos mieux vaut
mieux voilà mais en fait c'est tellement
monde pour tous les spectacles en fait
les gens sont tellement contents d'aller
aux têtes que oui jma il vaut mieux avec
trois yeux ok alors dites moi
vous êtes assez branché textes
classiques alors apparemment après
shakespeare et marivaux molière
exactement well as était bas pour le
400e anniversaire c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
un peu lent vie du
molière de françois de mazières le maire
de versailles de faire vraiment au
maximum un hommage aussi sur un molière
et quant au début de l'année il a fait
un peu un tour de table des compagnies
nous a demandé un peu ce qu'on avait
autour de molière et ce qui est drôle
c'est que nous on avait fait les amours
de marivaux les amoureux de shakespeare
mais on n'avait pas eu forcément l'idée
houle envie de faire autour de molière
et là c'était la bonne occasion et oui
c'est pour le cn trilogie finalement
bassin indien une voilà c'est fait et
d'ailleurs je me demandais juste petite
question à part comment est ce que vous
avez été recruté par la ville comment
vous à trouver et bien c'est justement
françois de wazières donc le maire de
versailles qui était venu nous voir à
avignon qui en 2016 je crois oui
2017 bref nous avait programmé au mois
molière et l'année suivante il nous a
proposé de devenir une des compagnies en
résidence à lens pour nous c'était
formidable quoi mais oui j'imagine alors
du coup ce spectacle s'intitule au
s'intitule pardon les amours deux
molières est-ce que vous pouvez nous le
décrire un peu nous donner envie alors
les amoureux de moyens mais toujours
dans le même principe de nos spectacles
c'est pas une pièce entière c'est des
extraits de pièces de molière et là
c'est au tour voilà toujours du thème
des amoureux des scènes d'amour
donc on a des scènes de tartu des scènes
des femmes savantes des scènes de 2 des
moins connus aussi on a le sicilien on a
le bourgeois gentilhomme qui connut bien
sûr évidemment et voilà on a fait un peu
un medley de tout c'est tout cpie scène
de ces pièces là et nous ce qu'on aime
bien c'est tout en respectant le texte
classique c'est qu'à chaque fois le
texte entièrement préservée et c'est
toute la sauce autour qui qui transforme
la vision je dois dire que là on est
peut-être on s'est permis un peu plus
encore de liberté voilà mais vous êtes
terrible
défend sans limite là ça devient un peu
serré au 8 mai mais on était même bien
chapeauté par
shirley dino c'est ce que j'allais dire
alors dès le début de votre jeune
carrière vous avez été mis en scène par
shirley dino qui est un couple
d'humoristes célèbre et qui se trouve
être vos parents accessoirement et donc
qui vous aide c'est ce que je voulais
savoir c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui
c'est ça c'est que ça fait quelques
années que c'est de moins en moins de
l'autre les deux premiers c'était
vraiment avec eux entièrement et la bola
et cette année on a fait encore moi
c'est à dire qu'on a vraiment tout créer
tous les quatre l'accord
les on a choisi les textes on a choisi
les personnages on s'est mis en scène on
a trouvé vraiment les l'ambiance de ce
spectacle mais c'est vrai que on a aussi
pas envie de nous quatre d'être
décisionnaires on s'entend on s'entend
tellement bien il n'y a tellement une
belle alchimie qu' il n'y a pas un qui à
un moment donné veut prendre ou va
prendre le lead et donc c'est bien un
moment donné d'avoir un regard extérieur
et c'est vrai que
eux peuvent mettre le basser regard
extérieur ou avec du recul
bienveillant qui sait aussi comment nous
canaliser comment faire de toute cette
folie
pour la voir voilà antoine richer à
droite à gauche chez valérian voilà ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que vous êtes vous
changer de costume constamment ça va
très vite c'est un spectacle qui a un
rythme fou
et donc les deux sexes vous changer de
costume où ça bouge plus chanter aussi
on chante alors c'est quoi ces choses
alors là cette année on a pris les
bandes sons c'est vous la dame chic
voilà et bérénice et la droite
exactement c'est qu'elle sait vous savez
alors moi je suis
je suis parti du principe de fin du
personnage de la comtesse d'escarbagnas
ce qu'un
personnel comme elle s'appelle la
comtesse d'escarbagnas je connaissais
pas non plus comme on a tous lu ou alors
on a découvert aussi des pièces et
finalement on a gardé la voilà on voit
qu'elle a une cigarette oualalou
pas peur des mots et en fait je fais la
première scène enfin le début de la
première scène de don juan ou sganarelle
parle du tabac à quel point c'est
extraordinaire le tabac l'apologie du
tabac en chantant l'amour est comme une
cigarette voilà et bérénice là elle fait
une des scènes voilà là un peu bélise
dans les femmes savantes où elle pense
que tout le monde est amoureux d'elle et
donc le pauvre antoine subi
ces avances
très bien donc là les photos qui sont en
train de défiler qu'on voit ce sont les
photos qui ont été prises donc en
ardèche quand vous avez fait cette
fameuse avant première quelques jours il
ya quelques mois donc c'est ce sont les
personnages les costumes et c'est qu'on
va retrouver les 29 et 30 juin c'est ça
sa tête c'était formidable pour nous de
pouvoir faire une sorte de premier test
aussi pour voir comment était perçue
toute cette folie puis vraiment il ya
molière mais il ya aussi tout ce que
nous on imagine on voit les costumes ils
sont quand même bien haut en couleur et
c'est donc voir bourrelesque aussi
vraiment vraiment du burlesque mes
parents nous disent carrément qu'on
comptant vers le cloud non on est
vraiment sorti aussi de ceux de ce
carcan et cette folie qui nous dépasse
aussi parfois en fait tant versailles et
pour nous c'est un bonheur parce que il
ya un plaisir de jeu il ya un plaisir de
jouer personnel mais aussi tous les
quatre ensemble qui est assez
extraordinaire et je trouve qu'on a
beaucoup de chance de se trouver aussi
pour déjà pour vous et faire ex pour
explorer va exploser toute cette
fantaisie quoi voilà
tous les quatre pareil et dites moi
justement je me posais la question neuf
ans de vie commune ils pour une
compagnie c'est beaucoup c'est pas
beaucoup
moi je trouve ça beaucoup dans le sens
au jour
j'estime que j'ai beaucoup de chance de
pouvoir
partager tout ça avec eux depuis neuf
ans je trouve que c'est beaucoup et en
même temps j'espère que voilà on en a
marre des années parce que c'est assez
classique les compagnies sont en général
dure si longtemps parce que vous êtes
peu nombreux du coup enfin dès qu'il ya
un problème du rsa permet de régler tout
de suite
parce que contiennent campagne est très
nombreuse peut-être que les choses
passent aussi comme ça en fait je sais
qu'il ya des compagnies que je connais
pas tout mais il ya des compagnies ou va
y avoir un ou deux noyaux durs de oui et
après jour il tourne avec des comédiens
souvent les mêmes mais ça tourne un peu
mais c'est vrai que nous comme ça mes
parents avouent fait ça tous les deux
mais pareil il avait travaillé aussi
avec des autres comédiens mais à quatre
comme ça depuis automne un modèle unique
un belge je n'ai pas rencontré ouais
c'est l'alchimie de cette belle
rencontre
là nous voyons antoine richard valérian
et bérénice il est il et qui là antoine
alain antoine joue la var on est parti
de ce personnage et il fallait qu'on
m'explique pourquoi parce que voilà nous
ça part un peu dans tous les sens et il
est habillé en femme est en fête du foot
ou du principe que c'est parce qu'il est
tellement avare qui préfèrent porter les
habits de sa femme moins cher ils sont
de mise mais c'est tout à fait possible
au près pareil et dites moi comment à
quel s p a quel public pardon
moi je dis rien mais je vous laisse
parler
non je suis très très heureuse quand on
a joué là il ya quelques jours en
ardèche élever des enfants et c'est en
ça pour cent des vrais pas des ados un
an des enfants entre je dirais six et
dix ans et
et en fait il était mort de rire et ça
ça me touche énormément dans tournée
polliat sans connaître moyen d'entendre
le vrai rires des enfants qui ont les
super spontanée qui rit à nos bêtises
c'est à dire qu'il ya les adultes qui
rit mais c'est un autre rire forcément
parce que c'est toujours celui des
enfants de leur coeur mais les enfants
n'y a pas de réflexion c'est ce qu'on
voit la ss est de voir ça ça m'a
beaucoup touché même si on ne peut
toucher aussi les enfants ça me voilà
donc en fait ce qui est génial avec vous
ce spectacle c'est franchement il ya le
rire est un vrai rires c'est pas un
petit sourire comme ça et ça peut nous
réconcilier avec le théâtre avec les
textes classiques qui peuvent paraître
parfois aride et c'est vraiment une
belle occasion de découvrir molière à
travers vos yeux que vous montrer drôle
moderne vivant très vivant et alors
après la suite c'est quoi alors la suite
donc après le molière le 29 et 30 juin
on part à avignon et vous allez jouer
quoi là-bas celui ci que oui en fait on
fait un demi avignon c'est à dire qu'on
ne va jouer que du 7 au 18 juillet et
c'est un peu une première pour nous de
faire un demi à venir mais l'idée nous
plaisait bien donc voila et ensuite on
sera en tournée du 2 au 19 août avec là
pour le coup trois de nos spectacles
gratuits là les grands rôles et les
amoureux de shakespeare d'accord et donc
ces trois spectacles seront joués en
même temps le même soin où vous allez à
tercé allez on on a des festivals un peu
partout et plus il y en a qui nous ont
pris les amrchés avril à apprendre voici
d'organisation et j'imagine donc on peut
vous retrouver peut-être sur un lieu de
vacances cet été exactement vous avez un
site j'imagine peut voir modane oui oui
tu sera mis à jour exactement
bon tout cas un grand merci vous avez
une étude est à nouveau venu nous
présenter ce prochain spectacle qu'on a
hâte de voir on sait d'avancé que ça va
être génial donc donc allons-y alesi
tous et bah écoute et bonne chance pour
la suite et puis à juin prochain notre
rendez vous
traditionnel j'ai envie de dire merci et
vise à benicio être à bientôt
[Musique]
qui